[Music]
scientists have discovered
bottlenose dolphins
can recognize each other through taste
how they lick each other so can we what
the [ __ ] they licking licking lift god
yeah exactly you mean like you lick they
they lick
like that i've never seen your hair look
like that yeah how do they taste
underwater not exactly so what they do
is they
taste one another's piss come on really
really
disgusting so they pee and then the
other one comes up and just licks it
kind of like how a dog sniffs a ass
honestly that kind of makes sense
imagine like [ __ ] follicles that are
going through your like inhalation lungs
and stuff like that but like when you're
in the ocean you pee it's like gonna go
everywhere in the water it's unavoidable
so you've probably already developed an
immuno system that can like handle feces
in such a way in the water the pee is
actually clean you just demystified the
whole thing and they don't drink alcohol
or anything like that right yeah wow
the wonder mythbusters baby you're under
water and like you lick something if you
can taste it
let's try it apparently dolphins can i
don't know because i've tried to drink
seawater and it tastes the same but
imagine like it's not just sea water
right it's sea water and piss you've got
like me and my anime dumping hawaiian
punch on your [ __ ] head oh and now
you're gonna i think you get a little
bit definitely taste that yeah just a
little bit of wine punch so yeah
dolphins um or pee drinkers pee sniffers
real big time p drinkers not just that i
mean they were known before for being
also rapists so i think oh yeah yeah
yeah and recreational killers that's
what i'm saying yeah so i think they're
canceled now officially for being pee
eaters as well puffer fish to use as a
volleyball they rape them all kinds of
clams and stuff they rape all kinds of
different clans
seahorses [ __ ] up in this they're
pretty gangster
you ever seen killer whales trying to
[ __ ] with seahorses humpback whales have
you ever seen those
videos they gang they gang up on like
baby whales and they [ __ ] hit them
like a torpedo is that the black and
white ones yeah yeah the shamu they
don't try to get the parents are the
parents too big they just get what's
easier like it seems like it seems like
all wildlife they go after the baby oh
wow like baby down probably tastes
better the parents are doing tricks
though that's the problem the parents
are [ __ ] doing tricks at the surface
yeah not paying attention to their kids
what's going on
they're influencers they go on
instagrams and stuff they're two but
there's the
emo s dorsal oh yeah yeah come on get
that [ __ ] out of here dude
killer worlds are [ __ ] gangster
though yeah they are oh dude bro that's
scary
anything in water is scary to me large
large aquatic mammals are nothing to
[ __ ] with me
no but i'd be like down for whales but
like killer whales it's like even whales
that should scare you like all of them
can like can we all agree that there's
no better status symbol than having a
[ __ ] killer whale on your swimming
pool
i want to have check out the house i got
to kill her it's like y'all got my
[ __ ] killer where weren't there i own
i own an apex predator right here i
don't know
right there that's my tiger until you
want an animal black fish documentary
white bang white bagel tiger no matter
the [ __ ] what yeah sick freedom roy's
[ __ ] it's not like rare nft one the
hollow foil one yeah it's like whoa what
would you name it what would you name it
oh dude i'd name it i named it bengal
big bangle dude
oh my god
you just gave me a sick ass idea so
i wanna i wanna invite you guys over to
my house right
and then i'm gonna have like a moat
in that moat there's a killer whale but
when you guys pull up i'm gonna [ __ ]
time this [ __ ] out so when i see you
pull out you're gonna see me going like
this and then a killer whale's gonna
push me up i'm going into the sky and
we're gonna both backflip and go into
the water and i'm gonna get up and say
welcome to jamalia [ __ ] that is why you
are next level and i'm down here you're
up here and i'm down here
we're just simple men just another
example
you know what's sad though i used to
always go to san diego to do uh sea
world to watch all that had an annual
pass and then i wanted to be in the
front with the raincoat on my [ __ ]
parents hated it i wanted to get
splashed and you see shamu [ __ ]
dancing and [ __ ] and i was like oh
that's free wheelie dude by his real
name telecom it's free willy it's willie
it's shamu and free will yeah but
they're also too busy killing the
trainers over there telecom dude do you
guys ever fetch him before that i've
never been to sea world me neither i
[ __ ] did
i got the [ __ ] feed chamois did you
get that
did you throw it did you throw the
sardines into the tank and stuff no dude
i threw popcorn in there
there were licorice in there bro do they
still do that do they still let kids
like [ __ ] throw sardines and [ __ ]
like that [ __ ] fish they don't have
the dolphin no i thought like didn't
they get like a bad rep after some
doctor sure yeah blackfish i saw my
annual pass i just saw him like [ __ ] it
last week i'm just saying back in the
day as a kid you could go there they
would bring up the [ __ ] dolphins you
like petting it's tongue and [ __ ] you
know yeah well didn't they spit in his
mouth didn't they stop all the
entertainment but they still have the
dolphins really yeah because i remember
when we got to feed the dolphins right
man they're they're like a gang dude
they were so [ __ ] up when they come
out
they're all [ __ ] this one's got like
a scar this one got an eye patch and
[ __ ] this one's all [ __ ] up this one
has no [ __ ] thing does missing a
finn's got a hook dude they're all
[ __ ] up they look like pirates of the
caribbean has one goal you know it's
like it's like when you're it's like
when you're walking your dog if you've
ever had one and then you see some white
lady and then she's got a dog and then
she's like it's like oh hey there's a
cool dog she's like it was a rescue and
you're like god
you live react in front of her that sea
world like whenever
it's a rescue okay
sure it is yeah rescued from wyatt you
stole that dolphin you rescued it from a
net okay
yo but they're dicks though dude so you
would feed them and then they'll just
they'll get the food and get away from
me they won't let you [ __ ] pet them
dude you pet them a little bit and they
snap at you and [ __ ] they're depressed
they're [ __ ] dead speak to the
[ __ ] manager i wanted to pet a
[ __ ] dolphin
i wish there was someone there that all
the kids were like oh he's not coming
mommy he's not coming tyler come over
here that's what i kept hearing they got
a big [ __ ] stick and they pushed that
dolphin over closer
because i was making so much noise
because you got a season pass yeah i got
to see spencer
[ __ ] pass holder [ __ ] look at
it stick it on the glass keep looking at
your piece of [ __ ]
and yeah they just just poked it over to
me and i was like why are you so good at
that who in your circles it talks like
that your [ __ ] wife does
your [ __ ] wife though that's what
it's called
why do i take this
why do you show up for the show
the pass holders are different man
they're more entitled
seaworld one they spend big seriously
legoland on the other hand what else is
that sea world dude it's honestly it's
the otter show so it's a bunch of shows
like it's just
they don't do as many shows now the
penguin like like speedway or whatever
you call it the arctic arctic circle i
think it's like a yeah it's something
like that it's the arctic circle
f1 or p1 or something
ever since the documentary they've been
reducing the amounts of [ __ ] really
because it's exploitative so they're
like they'll do like uh did you shut up
they'll do educational presentations so
they'll be like oh this is this thing
and it does this but they're not going
to make them jump through hoops anymore
so it's not like an aquarium so it
thinks these people will sticks up their
asses dolphins and whales have to look
at toys instead of getting to play with
toys
yeah they just don't want to like demean
the animals much it's more like they're
mean
have you ever seen the [ __ ] sh when
the [ __ ] show and the otter and then
the seal chase each other and they're
doing cocktails that show was great oh
it's the same show where like the the
drugged up lions jumped through a hoop
of fire and burns themselves i don't
know if they still have that one i know
that i don't know which ones they're
getting rid of but i just remember
reading that like most of the shows are
not well like i think it's so much just
because of things like the documentary
where it's like oh we're treating the
animals wrong but it's also like the
animals had like after a certain amount
of years probably killed like three or
four trainers like maybe it's time to
stop they'd be drowning in the trainers
for you i was at a zoo thing in like the
late 1990s and they did the lion ring
thing when they set the ring on fire and
then the ring got put out but just
before the lion jumped through it and i
was like i want to see the [ __ ]
manager
the rig master
where are the elephants playing
basketball i came to [ __ ] watch the
elephants
these outfits getting the [ __ ] [ __ ]
of three shoot at three
it got put out
where's the bear on the unicycle [ __ ]
that's a really weird that's a really
weird thing to do light it up and then
put it on
it blew up
oh it blew out yeah oh yeah lion's
jumping
dude i think i gotta i'm gonna have to
move to thailand evolving because i'm i
never got to see the barnum bailing
[ __ ] search i did i was sick see i
never got to see that it was lit so i
have to go somewhere where they still
have it yeah circus the ones that have
like freak shows and stuff everything is
that they're carnival some of them
they're the lady with the house they're
all they're all different now like now
it's all weird and like you know it's
but they don't call them freak shows now
they call them like museum of oddities
or something like that lame yeah
they're usually the greatest showman
with a hugh jackman oh really you know
where they don't have freak shows though
or west virginia oh because they just
call them people everyone just like i
went to the piggly wiggly i saw all this
crazier [ __ ]
get the circuit come to town and they're
like bearded lady that's my [ __ ]
mother is my bearded lady we're talking
about my mom has a beard well am i gonna
go pay money for this
kid me yo have you seen the whittakers
yes no oh i love that yeah bro
and they keep doing have you seen like
the newest ones wait what's the newest
update
it's probably one of the most inbred
families in america it's the generations
real quick we got the dolphins or piss
eaters right yeah we got that it's
not convinced it's it's the generations
of inbreeding yeah that causes oh i've
seen it there's like a brother that
barks yeah there's like
yeah
it's crazy dude that's all he does is
bark but no it's like for real like i'll
use it
they're doing pretty good now though it
looks looks pretty sweet and but yeah
like i i just watched it actually like
two weeks ago the newest one and now
there's like three other people there i
was like damn it's because they have
like other family members that didn't
want to be on camera that would come
around and help clean oh they do look a
lot better though it reminds me of the
jackson wines yeah they've been getting
a lot more money i believe yeah
it's because the director of that house
the soft white underbelly he he takes
care of him he helps them out yeah and
those this one episode they went to
walmart together yeah i saw that
fascinating thing and they ran into like
that family member ran into family
members yeah it reminds me of the
jackson whites have you guys heard of
the jackson whites no like these like
these um they were originated when like
these indians used to live like near
these mountains like near virginia and
so um
they like
kind of
integrated like the indians started
[ __ ] like runaway slaves
and then like they became like these
strange like albino um people that live
in the hills and so like the crazy thing
is like that was the story right that's
like the legend that was told it's like
in these areas like in these little
communities it's almost like there's a
stranger things going on we're like
people like there's [ __ ] up [ __ ] going
on like these people are living the
mountains and it's [ __ ] weird but
like it was really just like they were
runaway slaves who ended up breeding
with this indian tribe and they
wanted to stay remote and away from like
civilization and so they were everyone
called them the jackson whites in that
area but they were white they were like
albino oh wow configuration and like
like but there were all kinds of like
legends being told about them like were
like they were creepy because of
inbreeding but because yeah because of
inbreeding they were creepy and stuff
and then maybe they had
vitiligo
people would say that they had like
apple [ __ ] sized heads and [ __ ] like
they would say oh no really all kinds of
should they look kind of normal yeah i
mean i could pull i could pull up some
giant like nothing you described looks
normal and then you go but did they look
kind of normal
albino vitiligo apple sized heads
and i'm so confused they're like they're
indian or are they white or are they
black
they're black they're black people that
are albino right
but that's what the legend is it may not
be true this is true it's it's just that
part of it's true right not all of this
oh
wow that's crazy
there's albino but then kids in the area
were taught like
you don't want to go in those [ __ ]
hills at night kill your [ __ ] eat you
and chips urban legend type stuff yeah
yeah yeah yeah just like the whittakers
they would say that [ __ ] about the
whitaker yeah it's all weird yeah
they're like sweet people honestly
though if i was like nighttime and i was
driving and you wrote anyone you just
hear like that guy barking yeah
that's how he could be scared you gotta
eat him first before he eats you one of
the things i was watching like the other
guy was like crawling and [ __ ] and in
the beginning i was like dude i'd be
scared as [ __ ] if like i walked across
there if you didn't know who they are
but if you got lunch with them and sat
down with them i would still be nervous
being around them honestly yeah like
even right now you need to open your
heart yeah dude you're that's judgmental
yeah whoa dude whoa hey turn the cameras
off hey dude what would shamu do that's
what i like to say you do a [ __ ] cool
trick no i've never been
you